[Music]
lgbtiq
rights in the european union are at a
defining moment
most europeans regardless of their
sexuality or gender
want to embrace lgbtiq people as full
members of our european family
they want an end to exclusion
discrimination and violence
but there are forces among us that want
to undo
what is being achieved we must keep
sight of the lgbtiq freedom zone
that we are building on the occasion of
world pride in copenhagen
let us remind everyone that lgbtiq
rights are human rights
these include marching in the streets as
visible members of the lgbtiq community
loving who you want to love and being
who you
truly are through a sense of a global
community
world pride sends a strong signal to the
whole world
that love wins over hate pride raises
awareness of current lgbt iq equality
issues
and the challenges for lgbtiq people
to be themselves and live their lives as
is right for them
pride stands by everyone's uniqueness as
full citizens of societies
with equal rights and obligations pride
is a political protest that keeps up the
pressure for
change combating inequality stereotypes
and structural discrimination pride is
about our shared humanity
we all want to live life to the fullest
be true to ourselves
and express that without fear the
european union
will do its utmost to build a world of
equality
where the rights and freedoms enshrined
in international treaties
apply to all without exception happy
[Music]
pride